it's Friday everybody you know what that
means
that's right everybody I'm bringing back
the old time favorite of this channel
Fridays with PewDiePie the Fridays with
me
PewDiePie that's me guys I had a promise
that I made seven years ago I made a
promise that if I hit a hundred thousand
subscribers I was going to strip on
camera how's it going everyone but it
looks like I'm already stripping look
how much skin I'm showing look at that
shaven chest you the pure the pure
feeling and welcome to can't even
understand what he's saying the accent
is so thick I literally don't understand
what he's saying who is okay that was
pretty dumb I will fight old Peter pie
any day I thought I'll do this vlog if
sort of things at least once a week okay
I actually upload a two-minute Q&A wait
but it's two minutes long when we list
it for us
if I get 100,000 subscribers I'll do it
guys next Fridays with PewDiePie I'm
going to strip it's going to be epic
check it out guys alright leave your
entries in the sir ready pros okay let's
see what kind of means you guys posted
this week predictions I don't know
actually I'm let's just check it out
thank you guys it's so nice that we have
Friday's repeat as a community thing you
know but we really appreciate each other
it's wonderful I'm so glad I kept it
going up vote if you want Marzia to whom
in a video
[Music]
that was not good minds yet that was
terrible
I'm really glad these reposts of memes
make it into PewDiePie submissions cuz
they're so funny are you guys excited
for I don't get it
it just says three and markiplier I
don't can you guys explain this to me
cuz I don't seem to understand what are
you doing later I want to go to dinner
you don't do dinner
why that's too bad I don't usually ask
twice but um [ __ ] yeah that's my tank oh
so now you're good oh she likes tanks
well no thanks
no tanks everybody great all these
gold-digging women sorry I don't mean to
say you're that old women are gold
diggers but it's it's clear soon as soon
as you roll off with at e3 e3 sorry as
soon as you roll up with at e3 e2 tank
all the sudden is different is this
cosplay
[Music]
fine you did it you did a clever cosplay
you made it into the why why is this in
the why I have this theory for a long
time that we need to send kids off to an
island where they fight for their life
and only the strong will make it out of
life fort damn it
I created fortnight the end of
civilization the end there's no hope for
the youth there's no hope for the future
[Music]
so this is with too simple class you
could command an army when you run out
of content hit that film everybody hey
it's working okay and it's funny I enjoy
it
so shut up guys stop bullying producer
why do you want a car that's three
99,000 because i like the design of the
lines look at those lines guys my chair
as well it's he's a little shy
okay give him time bread one bread tube
my 3.3 k uploaded post Oh see this is
what I'm saying
you can't blame me you gotta take it up
with Brad one and two tweet at them I
know the chair meme is outdated oh boy
oh boy what is it what is it it's never
going to be out it's clearly been
immortalize at this point just keep
going I don't even care
oh wow that's nice I mean honestly
another reason why it's such a great
price look how much you can use it for
399 everybody
[Music]
oh my god it's lost no oh my god I
wouldn't have realized damn it oh damn
it I kept refreshing oh yeah is this a
funny meme there's some seriously high
uploaded once this week ok so who's that
some random guy okay the Pope Pope means
Putin Putin means Trump Trump means
meatza Kim Jong Kim Jo means South Korea
president South Korea president means
Obama Obama means Conan Conan meets
Felix oh my god I've shipped the same
hand as Kim Jong
[Music]
that was great
I actually really enjoy that well done
handsome Jack's first animation
everybody that was hype since L EA is
using pita pies danger I decided to make
a new one he can't steal ha got you
ali-a good
that's so good you need to start working
on your own idea can we copy strike
DreamWorks then that is pretty crazy to
be honest I need to grow out my beer
just tad bit more upload if you want
Brad to make a video and Peter pyro
edited well I think I'm gonna edit a
video that takes effort okay not gonna
happen
dear pills we as your fans and your
nine-year-old army has realized that you
as our leader has been less enthusiastic
and energetic we know and understand
that getting married must be very hard
and stressful and you too must be
exhausting when you are sad and drop
hints about stressful life we care and
and we see and we care take a day two
days even a week off if that means you
will feel better we love you that is
very sweet I kept dropping these jokes
at the end of the video where I would
say oh I'm here tomorrow guys I do this
every single day
I really appreciate their concern and
I'm really glad that I have an audience
that don't like get mad at me if they
notice something they just show
compassion and I appreciate that but it
was the same thing when I made jokes
about running out of ideas I don't know
if you guys remember that was like a
year ago everyone kept joking
I kept joking that I was running out of
ideas and they became a meme so as soon
as I posted a video that was like hardly
inspired a bit uninspired everyone kept
going he's out of ideas oh my god and it
just kept forgetting reinforced as fact
that I was running out of ideas when the
reality
a ton of ideas for videos lined up like
it was not a problem and I kept making
this joke at the end of the video now
where I say I'm here every single day
guys every single day I let it just made
the joke because I don't preed record my
videos I upload like this videos see now
it's up it's recorded either the same
day or the day before because it keeps
them more fresh and entertaining that
way I used to pre-record back in the day
for example and a lot of youtubers do
but the fact that I record every single
day I think it's kind of fun in a way
you know it keeps going and it's kept
going for so long without a stop and I
kind of wanted just to remind people I'm
here tomorrow check out tomorrow's video
but then a lot of people I've seen a lot
of people coming about this saying oh he
seems really tired or he seems like
really a none energetic wait isn't the
true fat all if anything I didn't really
want to force the whole hey if I didn't
feel like it and sometimes I just don't
don't get me wrong sometimes I really
enjoy being a [ __ ] on camera fully
100% but a lot of times I just want to
act more normal and it's interesting how
if I act more normal it's like there's
something wrong with me or something
like that but that's a really long
answer thank you guys for the the love I
appreciate it not a little ice okay
everybody thank you guys so much for
submitting all the memes really enjoy
them it's always so much fun and I'll
see you guys tomorrow guys tomorrow I'm
gonna be here tomorrow that's right I'm
here every single day I'm here forever
it never ends it never stops
[Music]